[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si l'on pouvait retrouver les
guinguettes dimanche Au bord de
l'eau Bon sens c'est chouette tu serais
ma Juliette, je serai ton
Roméo Quelques Sous Perre Noir Nous
vendrai son tout dernier tableau bon s
chou tu seras ma J Je ser ton
Roméo Sion peut retrouver les guing
dimanche
Au mais la mar cou temp coulé pour
passer le temps et tenté d'oublier ses
les jeûnes passés sont brillants
dans ad dieu nos gens et adu les guet
dimanche Au bord de
l'au les romans bleus vont se tisser
ailleurs et dans d'autres
berceaux fini la fte le populo parti
fini le
cabou mais c'était chouette pour toutes
les juliettes et tous les
Roméo quand onit retrouver les guettes
dimanche Au
B Le Soleil à briller pour d'autres ét
moi loin de la cité plus de rhums un
Instant etons le temps retrouvons le
gens si l'on pouvait retrouver les
guinguettes dimanche Au bord de l'eau on
chanté je sais chouet tu seras ma Juliette Je
serai ton
roméo pour quelqu'un s per noir nous vendra
ils sont tout derniers
tableau p chou tu seras ma
Je serai ton
ramé si l'avit retrouver les guing
dimanche
Au
dans Je serai ma Juliette Je serai t
néo
oui retrouver
[Musique]
ils retrouveront qu dimanche Au
bardel